good morning millennial good morning
Olivia this show was like so
under-the-radar cuz we didn't post a gas
card but that's what you get when you
become like a regular host thankfully
you're on Ben's level now even though
this is only your second time hosting
well as you know what the problem is
what so I actually have no photos alone
and so the last time that we were going
to make a guest card for when I
co-hosted last time I sent Claudia maybe
like 17 potential photos that we could
use nothing works because I never take
photos by myself I'm awkward I find it
weird I don't like that make sure that
cheese was from when we went from when
we went to LA two years ago no totally
attracted those the only photo that
works so I was like oh look called
making a guest card for me thus we're
not making and it was a picture that I
made you take because like you were
doing a photo shoot for me like being
the good momager that you are and I was
like [ __ ] give me the camera like you
look so cute we're in such a pretty
location and they took some model shots
of you and you're welcome I never do and
so that's also part of the reason why I
don't have a permanent guest card well
if you ever need another photo shoot you
know where to find totally always happy
to repay the favor I don't know if I
will but I will certainly let you know
if I do remember when you used to take
all of my photos when we live together
yes and now like exactly exactly that's
good photos I would still say that
whenever people ask me to take a photo
of them I I would say that I still take
the best like when we were at the
Bachelorette like hiding was Kendall and
I were trying to take a picture and we
were like who should we ask cuz there
are some people in the group who are
very in tune right you I suggested
Kristen because she was close of course
there are some like some of my friends
who um who just who are not Instagram
friends which is fine which is totally
fine but you just don't go to them and I
I don't mind it because I'm happy to
help you get the shot because I also
know that if I take the photo we will
take 1/3 of the photos that we need to
take because I will be good for you yeah
but we used to like walk out the house
and like literally like NY Street oh
yeah when we lived in Chelsea your
sister prefer my neighborhood yeah the
best when I moved to Chelsea I moved in
with Olivia and Danny and we I was
moving to Chelsea like I was like oh my
god like fierce as [ __ ] so I just like
felt this obligation to bring the
fierceness for my neighborhood which was
what we would do every day we would go
out and capture the fierceness well see
we look like an episode of Inside the
Actors Studio because we're in all black
oh yeah I was gonna look to see
and then I was like you know what I
don't really care but also I saw big
rage sitting like this so now I'm gonna
try to sit like this and see like what
it's doing for me yeah I always cross my
legs and I like switch off between the
show but my legs are incredibly secure
the number one thing is that he knows
what's be comfortable yeah yes I know
comfortable and look good yeah but like
if you're like this this you can't like
yeah but if you're like like take your
chair which I would I would sit like
that I go like this you have a lean
whatever works for you anyways we're
happy to have you here thank you for
filling you here thank you for filling
in for your sister and your other sister
who just have left me but for good
reason because they did dr. Wilbur
theater it last night and it looked
incredible it seemed incredible everyone
said the most wonderful things about it
both Claudia and toasters alike like all
the content I've been seeing on hashtag
dirty work really brilliant wanted to go
I had my Amtrak booked something came up
and yesterday that I could not attend
and I honestly like I don't really get
FOMO that often but I truly had FOMO
from not being there like that is just
so epic and I was like it's such a
once-in-a-lifetime thing that like knock
on wood will be like so many more
once-in-a-lifetime is it so amazing it
was like actually but then she also said
Atlanta was very similar she just didn't
know it at the time yeah but it was just
like a big moment the first of many big
moments exactly and I wish I could have
been there too but I take solace in
knowing that she actually doesn't like
when were there like she prefers us to
not be there because it takes the
pressure off yes I know yes I makes it
feel like more of a big deal when your
whole family comes to see your recital
yes but she also she you know Claudia
doesn't like to be alone like she does
like love having us there you know she
just she just needs this Mitch like one
person so I knew she was okay and there
will be more well bear theaters to come
so I'm headed me to and some will be at
the next one will be at the next one
your hair is getting so long like it let
me so good you like it I personally do
because I'm a long hair freak but I like
really have been noticing that it just
looks amazing Thanks well I'm growing it
out for the wedding and I'm really
excited to just be a wife because one
because someone on Instagram said this
mean I feel like they put it perfectly
like with long hair I'm Sheryl blossom
and with short hair I'm Penelope blossom
her mom got it and so for when I'm a mom
like I
want that mom haircut I find the shake
their party free baby dance right but
soon that will be my life and like can't
wait like when Kim and Chloe we're
wearing their mom bobs to that poker
night in LA don't watch but yeah what a
vibe no he's on their instagrams but
anyways it was a birthday over your
Bachelorette I know that's how much fun
we were having I didn't even realize I
know that the Queen was born how old is
she now like 37 38 I think Wow let her
look Helena like literally like she
makes like people want to be 38 totally
I think actually Cornish azar started
that because Courtney was like always in
her 30s when they were in their 20s and
like no one ever could wrap their head
around the fact that Courtney was 30 I
remember thinking that to that I was
like oh my god she was like older than
them but she's in her 30s and I'm like
but she looks so good and like her kids
are so cute and I'm like that's that's
glam 30 no but she had like a period of
like five years where she just really
like threw in the towel she was just
wearing like way too much Allyson Olivia
and like low buns and I love Allison
Aaliyah but there's such thing as like
too much yeah and like always in a bun
and like looking sad and like I don't I
don't know what she did to revitalize
like every bit of her but I'm here for
it I feel like when you get your groove
back like there's so many other aspects
of you that are like get into ya know
and it's like if you think about it when
Kim was our age she was just like I
don't know making it's just like
starting out you know it's never too
late to follow your dreams of becoming
the most famous reality star in the
world agreed anyways I was about to go
into the fat side but I was also about
to say something else that I do not
recall so maybe it'll come back to me
and if it doesn't it wasn't that
important are you ready for the fast eye
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast yes I am oh wait okay we
have some really fun stories for you
guys this morning because first up is
just something that I thought I'd
dreamed it's like when you have a dream
and you wake up and can't remember if it
was a dream or your life and this is
both clueless movie remake in the works
as if clueless is getting a remake
Paramount Pictures is developing a
remake of its 1995 comedy with girls
trip writer Tracy Oliver producing
sounds very in tune so far seriously
marquita robinson a story editor and
writer on the Netflix comedy series glow
has been hired to write the script I
don't watch a show do you know but heard
good things okay clueless direct
written by Amy Heckerling was set at
Beverly Hills High School and start
Alicia Silverstone and cher Horowitz
along with Paul Rudd Breckin Meyer
Jeremy Sisto CC - Brittany Murphy very
sad and Dan had dieters the film was
produced by Scott Rudin and Robert
Lawrence was loosely based on Jane
Austen's 1815 novel Emma which is just
like the best part
so looking like they're gonna bring it
back which I'm so here for it only if
it's done well and it's so hard to do
well yeah so I I I'm I remain skeptical
yeah but hopeful it's so funny because I
think empty always describes Alicia
Silverstone as like the actress that
could like never make it happen like
after her one big break you know she was
in that Kyle Richard show the American
woman did not get renewed for another
season so I hope that she's not in it
for the sake of the fact that I wanted
to be successful she was in that show
that we watched Suburgatory yes that was
a good show she wasn't a good character
oh she's also in book club where she
please Jane Vaughn
oh she plays Diane Keaton's daughter
okay and it's just like she's like has
no business being there because she's
just like you recognized her face and
you're like wanna get excited that she's
in a movie but like then you're just not
i completely agree and then you're so
disappointed that she couldn't be
further from cher Horowitz exactly she
is not her like she's very like green
earthy not sure not material it just
totally fine because you can be whoever
you want in the real world and act
yourself away but I totally agree in the
sense that just holistically like she's
just I don't look at her and like wanna
I want to think share heart what's what
I don't yeah also if they're doing
casting and you need someone to play
amber I'm a hundred percent available
just think about it I can definitely be
found rifling through Cher's hamper what
do you think would be a good cher
Horowitz stuff Cameron who's playing her
on Broadway yeah
Shaco but I don't she probably won't cuz
that's like too obvious of a choice so
I'll have to think a little harder I'll
probably be someone like Kiernan Shipka
Jackie I was just going to say that but
I don't want it to be her man she's busy
yeah she's like a little too stoic for
me she doesn't like have that much
personality or maybe I just view her
character from Mad Men though yeah but
like she's very like yeah I have to like
think of or even like
Sabrina carpenter Payton list like that
whole like Disney yeah I'll take that
serious you look at real actors Lily
Reinhardt yeah but she she's really not
sure as we saw him watch it I'm inside
like she's a very serious person I want
someone who like really embodies the
role like loves the movie as much as we
totally totally where maybe someone
could just either her bond maybe I
couldn't I don't know no I don't I
wouldn't wanna be too into it because
then um no I would say like never mess
with your hair because once like
something happens once you're done of
course but also I wouldn't want to like
see how the sausage gets made because
then it would be spoiled and I'm a
terrible actress so then the movie would
be bad and I don't want to do that but
like my do a terrible actress horrible
yeah I think I would be home which is I
am only putting myself up for Hallmark
yeah I mean cuz you have to be bad to be
on all mark but like oh you just don't
have to be like the greatest actor no
you just have to be cheesy which is like
when you're an actor and you're not like
an amazing actor I feel like if I was
acting and something I'm so acutely
aware of the fact that like I'm so
uncomfortable then it comes off as
cheesy right and I just feel like you
just have to look the part for Hallmark
and just get into them you just want to
be on hallmark and then like not you I'm
saying like hallmark actors like they
just they love that they're on Hallmark
and they embrace it and they just like
whatever they I hope they do they should
they're the number what one watch
Channel during the holiday season which
is wild to think about how many million
viewers why wouldn't they be because
like you know you want to be working
with Scorsese yeah but like you want to
be working or with hallmark or not
working at all I don't know actors are
weird bunch you know cuz they like
really the things that they value right
I don't understand I actually totally
agree with like they value like the
craft over like that Eddie Cibrian wants
to be a hallmark actor not in a Martin
Scorsese film Nick actively values the
paycheck over the craft right right
we're he's not a real actor he was like
a male model who like just you know got
a break right
he was the perm Ugly Betty we're all the
green also he was on CSI Miami I think
yeah I think so too
yeah that sounds right anyways um I'll
be patiently waiting and if you need
someone to walk the red carpet at the
premiere like I know you're a call girl
okay next story in more sequel ish news
you send me the story yesterday yes we
make sure that we spoke about it
and so many thought I could really have
chosen this one story as the Fast Five
of the how long we go on about I know
but I have a hard I have a hard out at
11:30 okay this Australian reports the
economic times a source that we have not
cited before this Australian billionaire
is building Titanic to to mark the 100th
anniversary of the infamous RMS Titanic
an Australian billionaire and
politicians has declared his plans to
build a replica of the ship okay maybe
this source isn't so legit because that
was horrible grammar no live Palmer the
man behind the idea plans to make the
Titanic to the unsinkable ship okay I
need to know here's the thing so that's
an old article this man no yesterday but
here's the thing get me a way it is
going the Titanic they are rebuilding it
they had a delay in production because
they had like a dispute over five
hundred million dollars or some [ __ ]
like that essentially it is going to set
sail in 2020 from Dubai and then go to
Southampton England and trace the
original path of the Titanic and then
from there it will go all around the
world as a wonderful cruise ship it will
hold the same amount of people they want
to literally replicate the exact same
thing just modernize it and I find this
to be a incredibly weird and let me tell
you I feel the same exact thing just
with enough life jackets in life yes to
support everyone on the ship which is
the only mail article no this is
interesting engineering calm and they
have all the details another source you
have an out cited right another source I
have you enjoy citing new sources
because this is a well-rounded show so I
could get it from the Daily Mail but
let's get interesting engineering calm a
chance okay
the project is being overseen by Blue
Star Line chairman Clive Palmer they did
get that right
who hasn't shied away from addressing
concerns despite controversy moving the
headquarters to Paris came in light of
tension between the UK and the EU it is
of little use having the European
headquarters outside of Europe the
decision will mean we won't open our
European office until March 2019 with
Paris being ideally placed to suit the
company's needs
Titanic 2 will also have enough
lifeboats and jackets for everyone on
the ship it will also have a welded hull
not a riveted one everything else
however will be incredibly similar to
the original ships documentation simply
updated the ship will follow the
original journey carrying passengers
from Southampton to New York but
she will also circumnavigate the globe
inspiring and enchanting people while
attracting unrivaled attention intrigue
and mystery in every port she visits ok
lovely can I say a couple things
it is brave season for these dragon
jurors I just feel like it's really like
weird Karma do you know what I mean like
this ship went down
it is like one of the most like notable
events in history with one of the like
the biggest movies ever made about it
and it's just like it's weird like
people died on the ship and now we're
just gonna like go on in and pretend
like it's a [ __ ] joy ride at Six
Flags like for me I feel like the whole
thing is kind of bizarre however my
friend Brittany Selene truly truly
believes that she was she's like a
reincarnation of somebody who died on
the Titanic she liked everything about
her life she like sees the Titanic and
everything she does is one of the
weirdest things on earth and I sent this
to her and she's like but she's so
excited she's like so down she's like
will you come with me I'm like
absolutely a boat on the boat like she
will prevail have her honeymoon like on
the boat seriously oh my god I mean
people are gonna go on the boat total
and it's just like really it's there's
something so weird about it but then on
the other hand I'm trying to think of
like similar situations where something
was knocked down and like should you
rebuild and um I originally was think
about the twin towers like do you think
that it should be the Freedom Tower
there that they should have rebuilt the
twin towers I don't know it's a really
interesting question but I also think
part of what they did was they really
like memorialize it and there's a lot of
respect there versus with this it feels
a little bit too like kitschy right like
we're gonna do it all over again and I
mean we're gonna have more lifejackets
and it's gonna be amazing like hard to
make a cruise ship like not kitschy I
understand but I just like the ass I
don't know I feel I just feel weird
about it I think it's so weird when I
saw it I literally thought it was like a
parody no I know it's well I feel like
all cruise ships are like a parody like
I don't think she'll rebuilt I and I
agree with that but I also think that
like you have to be in tune with like
what act like you have to respect what
happened when you are like rebuilding
the future of it right but rebuilding
the Titanic it's like you know copying
every detail it's not that crazy of a
thing actually because
cruise ships a cruise ship is a cruise
ship like they'll probably painted the
same and the inside they'll take like
inspiration from the Titanic so it'll be
more so of like a you know going on the
whatever ride at Disneyworld that's just
like an ode to something it's a
memorabilia right so it's not that we
are going to think of it in practice and
also like as a Jew like we have to
rebuild the temple it was destroyed
twice we rebuilt it but we memorialize
it like there's aspects of it that are
like in our daily life in prayers in
holidays where we're like always just
like trying to like I don't know the
right words right do not I mean someone
takes something down versus like
something like it's like we can't let
this iceberg win Jackie
totally totally the iceberg could it's
just an iceberg totally so I don't know
what are they gonna like play the movie
every night like 7:00 p.m. like we're
like an after-dinner show you know I
mean that sounds wonderful
I'll be there at the Museum no they'll
probably do like what's it called like
dinner theater where like people dress
up as Jack and Rose totally and like
reenact [ __ ] it'll be three hours with
it you know are they gonna do first
class second class and and I actually do
think that they have that I've never
been on a cruise but I'm pretty sure
that they have like based on his class
like sweets like things that are bigger
yes like anything else in our classes
society but like those what was that
called third class that doesn't sound
right
economy no but like what was it called
that oh I don't know I don't know I
don't know the Morea like actually sir
class might sound right
but they were like sleeping in just like
bunk like right right right exactly the
same Oh Jackie I don't know what that's
right I apply of Palmer
we gotta get right I've come around the
show boomerang we gotta get him on the
show now's the time he's like busy he's
busy but he's definitely like wants to
do press he clearly is a little thirsty
super my god there were some really
funny reactions on the internet that I'm
seeing now Adam rape on what Issa he
quote he quoted the story and said I
would rather fly spirit thank you yeah I
agree
that's amazing I need to read all these
tweets I'm really excited to see who
goes on it and what happen
like I'm sure everything will be fine
but this is like you know it's actually
kind of you were saying it's similar to
the first story and it really is true
like everything is a redo everything is
a comeback like nobody has an original
idea anymore and it honestly is really
kind of sad everything is like something
like something else or remaking every
single show that was popular in the 50s
60s 70s 80s I mean next thing you know
like friends is gonna be rebooted which
I'm sure people will be so excited about
but it only ended like what 14 years ago
like come up with something new I I hear
you sister i Riverdale's oh no it's not
it's based on Archie yeah who knows
let's say dynasty no it's not spacetime
dynasty yeah that's so scary Game of
Thrones Game of Thrones is original is a
rich and ghost on a book but yeah I was
thinking about that yesterday like oh
the Charmed billboard was in my face
like what are we doing people let's
obviously look at ourselves no one even
watched I'm like I'm almost pretty sure
of that like we grew up with CW was like
seventh heaven double you mean yeah the
WB that might be 11 surely nobody
watched charms like people turned it off
for charm I'm a hundred percent sure of
that because we watched everything on
The WB every he didn't watch charm no
and we also didn't really watch Buffy
the Vampire Slayer but we recognize that
it is popular yeah but like we didn't
really watch it all that much no cuz
we're not about spooky stuff no I accept
we did watch Sabrina the Teenage Witch I
have to say I am the most excited for
the toast Halloween episode like I don't
know if we can outdo do you know what
we're dressing I have no idea
I'll tell you how many I should tell me
later it's not that revolutionary but
it'll be really fun to be in character
the whole time yeah and be other people
so like we can really Ansel know but
it's just so funny you know oh it's
hilarious some girls at the at the
Boston show last night dressed up as me
Claudia in bed they looked amazing they
looked amazing amazing I mean my wig was
like a little ratchet but it's fine I
know it's hard to find a good right away
no but like they got the pink sweater
right twenties bajamas Ben honestly Ben
the Hat the whole shebang was amazing
amazing really truly good work you guys
will post a picture of it
next story Jennifer Lopez sparks
engagement rumors by flaunting a huge
diamond ring during the World Series
outing fans are now wondering if things
have
to the next step thanks to a piece of
jewelry worn by Jennifer Lopez when she
accompanied beau a rod to Game two of
the World Series on Wednesday
the 49 year old on the floor songstress
started tongues wagging by flashing a
massive diamond sparkler during the game
at Fenway Park yeah this ring is huge
it's totally an engagement ring say
something really quickly
huh on the floor singer like I have to
say like that song is catchy as hell but
like that's certainly no how would you
say she's the what singer anything I
mean Jenna block Selena I mean the
Monaro singer there's just so many
things the popstar I mean just anything
on the floor I mean that's daily mail
for you
[Music]
so I actually watched this story in real
time and I couldn't believe that it was
news because if you look at it and I
always do this now that I have a ring
but you can know which hand is the right
hand in which hand is the left and she's
wearing that big-ass diamond on her
right hand she's wearing it on the wrong
hand
I believe no your attitude it depends no
it's it's flipped so it mirrors exactly
what you're doing it depends what
platform she shot it on but it was
Instagram so it mirrors that he turned
the phone like at her do you know what I
mean I was pretty sure was the wrong
finger I was thinking deeply about this
no here look let's let's do an
experiment okay oh wait [ __ ] okay put
your hand up to your face now
if we're looking at this picture that
looks like your right hand right right
where right so I actually think it is on
her left hand and maybe they are engaged
interested then why wouldn't they put
out an announcement like I guess this is
her announcement and she wants people to
like go to her Instagram but like so
many followers that like one I don't
think that's true it's never enough
she's still doing the residency and
because even oh did you see Lidia is
doing a residency in Vegas I meant to
send that's you that is like so exciting
to me like at the Palms I'm so down I'm
so down and when I go to Vegas for all
of my residency stops like I'm going to
Vegas for a sober trip of just seeing
concerts I would like to be sober like
you wanting a wine like one wines like
just like
enjoy it I really now like enjoy not
drinking I love it
I'm with you this umbrella of not
drinking like coming home and being like
wow I threw a 5 hour event and I didn't
drink like I know so you wake up the
next day and you feel so much better so
like I really really have not been
drinking just because it really speeds
up the weight it speeds up the weight
loss it's amazing for your skin like I'm
already tired as hell from all my
workouts which I know everybody is
following and enjoying at the live
method and I'm loving meeting literally
so many toasters that go there every
time I'm there like somebody else is
like either like I'm here because of you
or like I love someone came up to me and
was like Jackie said she wasn't sure if
you're gonna be on the toast tomorrow
you're gonna be on the toast I was like
yes I was as far as I know but um I
drank like I went out to dinner with my
friend sandy like three weeks ago when I
literally had two glasses of wine and it
was a two day hangover like it was
horrendous and I even went and worked
out the next day just like sweat it out
it did not help on your Bachelorette
like I we pushed through because like
you got to do it when you got to do it
but like I just do not feel good when I
drink and honestly like I'm not even
enjoying the aspect of drinking that
much anymore lucky there
I still believe wine and I love good
wine and tasting wine and all that sort
of [ __ ] but I don't know like I took one
or two shots on your Bachelorette and
people were like in people being Danny
and Claudia we're like you know cheering
me on like trying like so hard to like
dance I'm calling it operation Olivia
because like I just will not like take a
shot I can't yeah no I I go from like
I'm either zero or 100 and 100 or 100
they'll be a so amazing at zero which
also looks like my Bachelorette weekend
so I have to be a hundred and now like
100 for me will only happen like once a
quarter probably whereas it used to
happen once a week Jackie and I'm here
yeah anybody even multiple times a week
I used to drink so much right thanks I
used to drink every single night going
to different events dinner dates this
not in the other always living in
Chelsea bringing the fiercest for our
neighborhood like of course we're gonna
drink yeah
people change life changes yep you got
to do a morning show now and it's hard
when like alcohol just slows you down
totally so so anyways congrats JLo
yeah I think um I think should they
probably are engage like that
Stephanie I mean definitely I feel like
everybody's definitely been waiting for
that to hop in and I would be very happy
for both of them I actually like really
like the both of them I love a rod on
Shark Tank and I just like in general
it's actually really nice to see they're
like blended family whenever they hang
out together like I am if they're
engaged I'm I'm here for it but like be
normal about it and like have an
engagement announcement don't like no I
actually prefer that you do I don't mean
a People magazine exclusive engagement
announcement with like your press
release no but like just post it on your
Instagram instead of this stupid
speculation like is JLo engage star was
wearing rings but not the next day not
wearing ring and then we'd like our
following story for three months about
if she's wearing a ring on no but to me
she's wearing an engagement ring on her
engagement finger she is engaged not
confirmed but yes but on and she's
trying to show us so she's engaged
okay so jail is engaged Jackie said it
congratulations
I'd like like most celebrity couples I
don't know if they will get married
right um but I'm glad they're taking
their relationship to the next level
even though like I've read some lines
that like I've read some lines too and
here you know what somebody
relationships like just operate at a
different I totally in a different world
from ours like and there's different
expectations and there's just like
different rules goodbye
whatever works for you people and like
it seems like their kids get along so
like at least there's new friendships
being formed no it's new brothers and
sisters I love that love it next story a
little business
Netta portait turns to Alibaba to sell
more $2,500 bags in China I just find
the story to be very interesting one of
Nana Corday's best-selling items in
China right now is a studded Valentino
bag that cost $2,500 the luxury retailer
wants to sell a lot more of that kind of
fashion item in the growing Chinese
market and it has tapped the country's
biggest e-commerce company Alibaba to do
so you extend a port a and Alibaba are
establishing a joint venture to launch
two mobile apps for Chinese consumers
one for metaphor day which caters to
women and one for mr. Porter which sells
men's fashion net aparte and mr. Porter
will also launch online stores on
Alibaba shopping website team all the
companies didn't say when the apps are
the online stores would go live net
apart a launched Chinese version of its
website in 2013 before it merged with
uc's in 2015 I didn't really say merged
I didn't either I like uc's
yeah me too I like and I like an
important
and I like Alibaba Swiss luxury
conglomerate rich him ah
gain control of the combine comes
earlier this year Richemont chairman
johann rupert acknowledged that teaming
up with Alibaba gives the group access
to a better platform in China this
sounds in tune across the board and I
love like when high fashion like
recognizes that they need to like come
they are accessible they need to go I
want to say two things about this
article number one there's nothing in
this world maybe there is actually a lot
of things but that bothers me more than
it being Mehta port a and mr. Porter is
it mr. port a like I just don't
understand no it's freaking weird number
one number two the reason why I think
this is amazing is because if you live
in New York City you can get same-day
delivery with net a port a if you order
a shirt online they will literally
deliver it to your door and maybe you've
seen some of these trucks driving around
but it literally looks like the Madame
Paulette ban it is very like it's like
that big like Mercedes like Metris that
you get in a via you know like and by
the way for those of you don't live in
New York Madame Paulette is the
drycleaners through the Stars owned by
John modeski and during his boyfriend
and then they literally I think that
their marketing strategy is to buy a
million vans that they wrap they brand
the bus and they basically drive it all
around New York because I always see it
but net a port a does something similar
where they really like they deliver you
know that the clothes that are in the
back of that truck they're not like
squished together what not like it's a
nice big van and it like everything
about it is premium now on the other
side of that Amazon have you ever gotten
the same day delivery from Amazon and
have you ever seen the car that it rolls
up in no and now okay let me tell you I
saw an Amazon Prime delivery happening
it was like maybe a month ago outside
Zach's building the car I swear to God
should have been condemned it was like
the bumper was off it looked like it had
been in an accident it was like a
minivan there was so many packages piled
to the top it was just like first of all
how do you even like get around the city
in this rinky-dink car that is not safe
to drive and to like how are you like in
there was so many packages there the
whole thing was just like such a
disaster and I was just like this is not
premium I understand that Amazon
Amazon's not net a port a right and
that's what I'm saying with Amazon
like they are just like out out out out
out they don't care about like the
quality but like mixing like Netta
portait which is quality with something
that like is maybe a little less
out-out-out like I feel like the happy
medium there will be amazing
yes sorry that was a little hard to
follow but yes and I feel like with
Amazon it's like I'd rather have my [ __ ]
on quicker and from a rinky-dink ril so
I don't even see where it comes from if
I get same day but I've never done
Amazon same bags and like not that you
don't know it's out that you'll just go
to the store right no but I'm actually
the opposite I think I'll go to the
store and set and then I never go to the
store and then I just have to order it
online and I could have had it in half
the time I just ordered it when I knew
that I needed yes whatever anyways I
think this is just this is cool but
here's my question about net-a-porter
Alibaba for those of you don't know like
Alibaba sells everything in the whole
world including like really premium fake
designer bags so what will they do I
think that while I drop it down no but I
think that they'll really help with just
like the shipping and distribution part
of it no but you can buy like a fake
Gucci bag on Alibaba and a real one like
through their net a port a collaboration
like that just looks bad on both but is
are the products of collaboration or
it's like the back-end system that co-op
no the backend systems the collaboration
but you'll be able to buy a Gucci bag on
Alibaba from net a port a right but you
could also buy a Fuji bag like I don't
really not from net-a-porter Gucci and
Pucci have never been sold in the same
place before so this will be interesting
well they crack down on Fuji I don't
know yeah I've only loved to buy a
smoochie bag it's almost 11 11 but that
like I've never bought a counterfeit bag
I have not either I but I've really
thought about it
like and then what I realize is if you
like if I buy one counterfeit bag it D
legitimizes my whole handbag collection
yes but and I just say this like but
there are some really good fakes I have
been to China and where they make like a
lot of the Gucci ermes everything like
they literally make the fakes in the
same Factory it's the same everything
except just like the legitimacy of it
and I'm not saying you should do it but
what I am saying is there some really
good fakes out there that are made with
the exact same material and Alibaba I'm
pretty sure as a Chinese based company
so Fuji and Gucci might actually really
be this and so it's like why would you
knowing that why it's hard to see them
pretending no genome is our own societal
like that's how we label things that
like technically it's the same exact bag
one is just like Gucci Sam and the other
is not and you will pay like a four
thousand dollar difference just for that
stamp and it's it's like it's so [ __ ]
up to think about because I totally
agree but on the other hand I don't know
I'm torn I but I've never bought I've
never bought fuchi I've thought about
I've had this conversation with myself
before and I always come out saying it's
not worth it it'll be worth it to wait
for the one you really want for sure or
just like wear something else that I
have totally and I saw your closet or I
very much enjoy it yet oh my god my
closet or is up on our patreon channel
it was real it's watching it back I
enjoyed it so much more than filming it
cuz while I was feeling and I was like
is this interesting like blah blah blah
so interesting because I've been to your
apartment but I've never like seen the
intricacies and I also came before all
the art was up your closet is amazing
you have so many bags I like didn't even
know how many bags you had and it
honestly made me excited for when I move
and like he's how I orient things and
I've been collecting bags for over ten
years
yeah like every our my birthday like all
I want is a handbag and like that's my
hammock so like so many of those bags
are like my birthday bag for 10 years
yeah I have bags that like I worn call
it like and I try to keep them as nice
as possible because Trek they just come
back that Gucci saddle bag GRE Simo like
they brought they totally and who cares
are they do your saddle bag but here who
cares of things come back or not like if
you if it goes with your outfit and you
like it you wear it it's not about what
net-a-porter says it's a new style of
course but there are things you proceed
differently like remember when we all
used to wear like big hobo bags to the
club I hope that never comes back when
did we do oh my god everyone like the
Lauren Conrad days where we wore like
big yellow chuchi make bags with all
your [ __ ] in it and like that's what you
would wear on a night out yeah like I
remember at that time I was like wow how
do people ever wear like little looser
purses and now all I want is a little
looser purse so trans really do change
ever and if I in my heart if I felt that
like I wanted to be wearing a big bag it
would do it I would do it good but I
also am a little bag person like I am a
big bag person when I'm here in high
school just following trends I wore a
big bag but now
I can like make my own girls for myself
you do your own thing I do my I do my
own thing and it's just it's fun to
collect stuff and it's also they're all
memories you know totally like I can
remember any any night I ever anything I
ever did in my life by what I wore
so speaking of memories today is the
two-year anniversary of the day that we
filmed Claudia say yes to the dress
episode Wow where a self-portrait top
top shot jeans that I literally were
yesterday on the show thank God they
still fit um
and associates with a liitle Bob what
did you wear I wore the black shirt with
the zipper that I got engaged with with
really like tight black leggings with
like thigh high boots up to here so
everything just like looked like one
with a black choker easy yep easy peasy
else well I also just looked on my time
hops I also you have known yes
right cuz we've seen it like so many
times foot better but it's nice to know
that's now that I would wear today
happily and with my pink coat that like
they didn't let me put down when we walk
into the store and I was like holding my
coat and it's just like but it's not a
gave a pop of color and it matched the
matched Kleinfelds pop of color love it
um that's so funny I didn't realize that
I would you do say yes like it doesn't
work out timewise but if it had would
you have done say yes to the dress
I don't know I mean it's just not I like
you know I could barely like try on
dresses like in front of the sisters you
know like it's just not my personality
to be like ooh let's go try it on and
this is so exciting get the veil on I'm
like find me something that fits and
looks good let's go let's get out of
here so I love the idea for the memory
and I love like Claudius episode and
also just looking at my time hopped just
all of the dresses that she came out and
then I like don't even remember I'm like
and it was such a fun day doing it all
together but like it's not necessarily
my personality you would be fantastic at
it I would have loved I would have liked
to have done I definitely would have
been stressful but at and Claudius a was
stressful even for us and we weren't
doing anything but it was I think it was
worth it because it's such a nice memory
to have but they film in the fall and I
had to get my dress before then so like
I don't think they were interested in me
like acting my way through an episode
well knowing I already had a dress and I
wasn't even like lie yeah so and I'm
also a terrible actress
so yes it just didn't work out timing
wise but you never know next oh yeah I
was always like you never know what the
future will hold
they say admission for your kid next
time Ramar go next first niche we'll
plan our wedding you're on say I could
really go for another episode and then
it'll be interesting to compare the two
cos we'll all be like the same at
different yes I think a little a lot
more different than we think but I feel
like I'm still the same as I was to your
you know when you like look back on
pictures and you're like how did I wear
that like what was I thinking when I
looked at now because you're still in
like the same life phase now but like by
the time Margo like you'll be married
like maybe you'll have a kid like it
will be different yeah that's true
let's show we didn't have Theo back then
right we were in all an statuses
no just just regular just you had it in
your heart ready to be ready to be an
on-stage always the work of an aunt has
never done was the funniest caption on
anything I've ever seen like I just was
truly laughing so hard oh my god so glad
yeah sometimes I like especially with
Instagram now like there's so much all
the time just another text from the
morning toast yesterday cardi B had
tweeted that her her Neffe her I used
her nice when you pull and told everyone
her aunt is cardi B and now cardi B has
to go show up to school because the kids
didn't focus didn't believe her so now
she has to go up to show up to school to
show the kids and I captioned it
announce work is never done
which is true and I'm glad you enjoyed
it yeah I don't even get the chance to
like like things anymore like sometimes
they go to your page Margo's page grunge
blonde clawed with no job and I
literally just like I go through and I
just like oh yeah but I'm always like
seeing things I'm like I just laugh to
myself and then like I keep it moving
but like sometimes I really forget the
light because it's just there's so much
going on especially with memes sometimes
I forget to like it yes I look it's it's
just there's so many it's just like you
read it you laugh you keep moving right
which is a which is great too okay fifth
and final story is like shocking and and
definitely different than our usual
stuff but Casey Anthony is dating a man
seven years after murder acquittal quote
who can overlook her past Casey Anthony
is dating someone new a source close to
her tells people the Florida woman who
was famously acquitted for murder in
2011 in the death of her two-year-old
daughter Caylee mostly lives a low-key
uneventful life in South Florida home of
one of the private investigators who
worked on her case wait
oh she works she lives with one of the
private investigators who worked on her
case that's weird
she had previously gone on a handful of
dates with different guys according to
the source but one particular guy has
caught her attention the source says a
man in his early 30s who works a
professional job they've been seeing
each other for about three months
quote she's had trouble finding guys who
are interested in her and the insider
says but he's really a special guy who
can overlook her past um okay I have so
many of so many thoughts about this like
what this guy pray for him but here's
the thing like I feel like if you're
Casey Anthony like why are you going to
People magazine about your new
relationship like don't all you like
that just like her being thirsty you
know like yeah yeah I think we don't
necessarily know if she went I mean I
know that I did but I'm just saying we
don't know hundra but something she got
married there's a marriage announcement
like someone when two people touching
somebody Casey Anthony like if she
really is who she pretends to be like
she should be wanting to live a low-key
life like her daughter like issue should
have ceased her name I believe done
something different she acts like she
didn't kill her daughter right so to her
she's like a mother who lost her child
like why are you still living where
you're living
yeah but to the rest of us she's a
murderer well and this is the thing so
it's like if you're a murderer like why
you being thirsty in People magazine
either way lay the [ __ ] out of my
magazines I agree and I would also like
to say one thing while I believe that
she 100% did it the reality is is that
it is technically an unknown because she
was acquitted right thus how can anybody
date her because they will never be able
to trust her how can you take anything
she says at face value she could date a
fellow felon a fellow accused murderer
yep that could work maybe Steven Avery
oh I don't I don't even follow I don't
find that either but apparently again
the second one came out and I personally
stopped watching the first one because
I'm of the mindset that he did it and I
think that the bias of making a murderer
one it was the reason why I was so
biased in his favor was because like he
actually did it but we can have that
conversation a whole other day I don't
watch it I don't know I didn't follow if
he got like a you know appeal released I
don't know what's going on there but I
personally think he did it but that's
all I have to say and I think that she
did it too people are saying that she
went bankrupt after the
which is why she might be like selling
stories to People magazine but you know
what there's other ways to make money
without being a thirsty how much are
they paying truly like does anybody care
like they have I know much comes we're
talking about it's in when you see it's
a slow news day when you see Casey
Anthony you click sorry fair Chuck when
you see someone's willing to these Casey
Anthony click by the way the whole story
could be fake and she could just sell
something just because she needs me but
like get a job get you hire her change
your name move and get a job move to a
different country like you know what she
really should have done not killed her
daughter Oh side from that but if she
actually didn't kill her daughter like
she says she didn't then she should be a
crusader for a protecting kid and
project totally but she but she ain't
innocent and that's why her actions even
after the fact proof yeah where's her
documentary like I watched Amanda Knox I
have I know there is one really ain't no
did you watch Amanda Knox I did
wow that was high heaven that one was
very well done because clear what to
write it was not biased either way and
that's what I appreciate it like just
present the facts and let people make a
decision versus like putting your own
bias in it yeah I didn't watch make you
a murderer sorry I'm not familiar with
the bias that you that she did and also
Amanda Knox in my opinion from what I
remember didn't act like a freak she's
still not a freak like in the sense of
being thirsty no she's China literally
normal life I'm aliens but she thing she
did do a documentary but it's wildly but
it's also history I like I don't know
both sigh I understand I agree like did
she do the documentary or did someone do
the documentary about her no but she was
giving interviews and like let them into
her life but later so what was the
paycheck oh it's 11:11 make-a-wish it's
a bad picture baggage baggage tags it's
a bag [ __ ] badge with tobacco swag
I need to dream bigger but I also still
don't have a good you bet here's the
thing I think I'm very like realistic
and attainable dreams are wonderful when
they come true you're like so relieved
and then you're on to the next one I
totally agree speaking of dreams
um just a random segue but let's talk to
you so Tom you mean you guess car today
so your questions comment them in the
YouTube stream we haven't seen Olivia in
two weeks or was it three weeks I think
it was two two weeks maybe three maybe
three you've been engaged for
month now yes Sunday will be a month oh
yeah Saturday will be a month are you
guys gonna celebrate we will be
celebrating by going furniture shopping
which isn't a real celebration for me
but yeah so you have an apartment we
have an apartment we have just been
waiting for so long to get approved by
the condo board but we have which is
very exciting we're moving in two weeks
it's like a very busy time we both have
like so many things upcoming but we will
make it work we will make it happen I
absolutely hate moving so like anybody
anywhere who can like just help me and
give me pointers on like what to do when
are you moving um probably first week of
November right around your birthday but
not on your birthday that date is
blocked off at the big X thank God
because I'm just so tired of like people
being so busy on my birthday but my
birthday is on Election Day can you
think of anything no and I feel like
it's happened like some recent have so
every about like it depends on the leap
years but it happened I had the last
night on my birthday it was on Mitt
Romney Obama election really I bet I
remember that so vividly you're a jerk
yeah yeah and no but it's like it's
either on my birthday or my birthday
it's like the day after the elections
like everyone's still only talking about
the election it's like hello yeah are
you gonna like purposefully conceive
your baby around a time where you like
want it to have a birthday that it's
like perfect timing for you um no not
for me perfect timing for the kids
birthday to be so like uh do you know
the most popular birthday I think in
America is September 16th which is
because the parents are predicating from
December 25th to January 1st that makes
sense cuz we're hibernating right so
it's like I don't want to I don't know
if I want to have a summer baby I
wouldn't mind it depends when in the
summer like am i nine months pregnant in
July I'm not interested I really I don't
want to be like heavily pregnant any
summer so if I could avoid that I would
spring birthdays are nice but like there
are so many other people who have spring
birthdays you know I just want a healthy
happy child you know there's no like bad
months to have a birthday totally
totally we'll make it work regardless
but more so like I just don't want to be
nine months pregnant in August that's
all I'm trying to avoid i but then
people who have kids in September we're
nine months pregnant right now you know
don't do it then I say that you have to
literally conceive in August and then
it's like so my
in November and most schools their
cutoff is September or August so I would
have been in the following grade but our
school was the cutoff was December so I
was young for my grade would you rather
be old for your grade or young for your
grade you know what the thing about that
is is like it actually doesn't matter
whatsoever like in hindsight when you're
in it you're like oh she's the oldest in
the class she the youngest in the class
but like looking back on it now it's
like who gives a [ __ ]
no but like it still matters like I
you're the last one to learn how to
drive I didn't turn 21 until my senior
year of college I said that I'd rather
be the oldest and right but then but now
that we've graduated I love being
younger than everyone else like for the
six months that I am and like plus my
Botox like I'm just a child compared to
these people Charl broad child bride so
I don't know I guess there's pros and
cons to every pros and cons and so what
would you do would you accelerate your
child or would you use 100% oh yeah
you're an accelerator a million percent
yeah yeah and being young is like cute
actually maybe maybe if it's a girl I
would keep it like I would accelerate
yeah and for a boy I'd want him to be
like the oldest in his class like big
man on campus yeah that's fair whatever
whatever
um so how's the wedding planning going
the wedding planning is going amazing
I'm pretty much like done with
everything like I'm I literally have
almost everything that's incredible well
when Ben was here we told everyone your
wedding day I know I texted him spilled
the beans did you well I gave him
permission to spill the beans because
we're rapidly approaching I knew that
the next time I came on the toast I
would talk about it so like I I didn't
mind it getting out I'm also not the
type of person that's gonna make an
insta story like alert alert like New
Year's Eve wedding you know so you are
getting married this evening married
this New Year's Eve two months and
change yeah it's like nine and a half
weeks oh wow yeah two months and change
yeah it's so exciting on New Year's Eve
wedding is the best idea thank you and
it's just a dream I hope we're so
excited like it's gonna be so great I
would have loved to get married on New
Year's Eve but it didn't work out and
I'm so glad that you are because now we
have New Year's plans we would still be
like floundering like a New York fans
where everyone's gonna love ya and
everyone's gonna look great you know
yeah I hope I'm never in a club again on
New Year's Eve okay I mean this year
would be like but I will be drunk it's
perfect
yeah cuz no one ever has plans but you
want to do like the most you want to be
dressed to the nines like yeah a wedding
is the perfect occasion
totally so the wedding planning is
almost done so the wedding planning is
almost done it's actually like such a
funny story because the last time I came
on the toast I was like trying to hint
at the fact that we were gonna do a
short engagement like Zach and I've
always wanted one like if it were up to
Zach we would go to City Hall tomorrow
marry like we just want to be married
we're just like so excited to just like
live life and be done like we don't need
a long engagement or a production
although we respect the fact that people
do whatever they want and it's just so
funny how the world works because I
think it was it was probably a little
over a year ago where Claudia was
looking for an intern and this girl
Nicole I'll give you a shout out reached
out to me and she was like I would love
to be Claudia's intern and I would also
just love to talk to you and get some
career advice and she went I think to
Maryland with Ben's sister so she wasn't
like somebody like totally random and I
met with her we had coffee it was just
like such a lovely conversation and then
like two months later I happen to be on
the board of the yad vashem young
leadership association which is around
like Holocaust Remembrance and we do an
event I think they do an event two times
a year but it was the Spring Gala in
February was the one that I was on the
board of and Nicole and her family are
were the caterers of the whole event and
they're like huge kosher caterers they
do like amazing events and so when I
came on the toast and I was like I'm
probably gonna get married soon she was
like hello don't forget about my family
and I honestly totally had I was like
that's amazing so I called them Crystal
Plaza group in New Jersey and Alpine
caterers is the kosher caterer they are
just like doing like so many like
they're helping with so many things
between them and Josh from birch
obviously who's also doing yours and who
did Claudia's like everybody just has
taken so many things like off my plate
and so under way I'm like just so
excited and like that has been just like
so easy where so many people are like
also so excited and like so down to help
and be helpful and I'm like great my
invitations went to print I think
yesterday or the day before I have a
band I have a photographer I obviously
have a venue have a dress I have a dress
I'm going after this to go pick up my
dress hopefully it still fits no I'm
kidding
I'm working out like a monster everybody
knows so everything is like pretty much
our way we're going to Miami for my
Bachelorette that was my next question
how are you feeling what is the vibe
that you're anticipating I have to say I
really liked the vibe of yours where's
both party and chill to be honest with
you like party then chill or like a
chill party I don't know I think party
than chill okay so like mine was
ratchetness mine was the mist no I mean
here's the thing the people the Danny's
are the most ratchet so like I'm not
gonna get away with anything less right
they're not gonna let you and I knew
that about my bachelorette party but I
was still like I'm not getting pure
pressured into doing anything I don't
want to do so if I really don't want to
do it Hodel I'm not doing it but I knew
that I would want to like totally and
I'm like super down for like anything
and just like as long as people are
having a good time like I told everybody
take whatever flights work for you like
I loved how you were just like sleep
until whatever you want like I slept
until literally like 1 o'clock like I'm
I think on Sunday and like to be honest
to you I just like have not slept in a
month that it was like the best thing
ever and I just like I love when people
are like not neurotic about like we have
to be at brunch at 11:30 and I'm like no
like I just why can't me just it's a
vacation for every budget my biggest
problem is like I need to find like more
white things to wear which I think I
usually wear the kimono that I wore to
the pool party yeah guys like it says
the bride and it's like so cute has like
long amazing I'm just like that's what
I've been like looking like I wore that
stars romper from boohoo on your batch
on your Bachelorette which I like loved
and it comes in white I'm like great one
thing like but also when we went I wore
white too like the one day part like I
was like I'll just or like you should
wear I don't wear you don't have to
worry right the whole time like I wore
that paint trust the first night and
I've never felt like more of myself and
I felt like I know but that's you I feel
like my food is black but I shouldn't do
know where like if you want to wear
black oh gosh because like you don't
want to it's your about you act like you
don't wanna be wearing this like big
white dress like Who am I don't wanna be
like you're feeling the best version of
yourself totally no you're you're also
like not that girl like cheesy
bachelorette party no no and you know
what wear black sexy romper we'll put a
little veil in hello yeah yeah yeah so
I'm just all about do what you want to
do this is you were a trip
yeah no it's fair but I like also wanted
to be like everybody's trip like I just
want people to have fun like I don't
really care about the bridal aspect of
it it's just like it's an amazing reason
to get away amazing let's just how
I completely agree I think that's the
best approach like you're like now
looking back on these dear toasters that
we've gotten of like people who's the
bride's were being crazy about their
bachelorette parties or this or that or
making people plan [ __ ] it's like I can
tell you with certainty now before I was
just speculating yeah there is no need
for any of that and like you don't even
need to be this person's friend let
alone bridesmaids well you know what's
so funny and you guys were talking about
this as it relates to hashtags how like
just things have gotten so far from what
they need to be and like just
everybody's out of control
what's your match right hashtag I have
two options okay tell me what you think
okay
Harrah's comes the bride which is
amazing because Zach's Instagram as you
all know is here's a calm which the
story behind it is that like Zach didn't
have an Instagram for a very long time
and any time he was in a photo people
would just hashtag where's Zach calm so
when he finally made one it's here's a
calm but Margot Lewin thought his name
was Harrah's before meeting him so now
everybody just calls him Harrah's
so that's funny and then here comes
Brian Harris comes the bride I love that
and then never gonna be like a good
hashtag to accompany your wedding yeah
well Sandy's thought I should do live
goes mi a oh I love that so like and you
can always do Livio no mo I totally
could like if you ever need a backup I
could also just do yo Livia you know
yeah
Oh or ya know Liv goes mi a someone just
said something so funny they were like
my Bachelorette was funeral themed we
were mourning my singlehood I mean you
not feel that did you where I hope you
were all black yeah well and then the
thing also is is like we're in I think
you're in a too like the toaster is
getting married group and it's like it's
so helpful it's amazing to see what
other people do but it's like some of
the expectations that other people have
for you as a bride is out of control
like I saw a whole thread about like
we're supposed to give like giveaways to
people um hello like you're supposed to
give gifts to us I don't need you to
give you a [ __ ] gift to come to my
wedding don't come like what's a
giveaway like I don't I never had even
heard of that but the fact that that's
someone's expectation I like the hell no
you don't get a gift for coming to my
wedding
no oh my god yeah I'm the gift totally
that's so crazy just so are people and
but like do that if that's what you want
to do well because other people are like
what have to do
like if I had someone in my Bachelorette
who was like wow she didn't get us
anything I'd be like get the [ __ ] out
totally get on the next flight but no
one that was there would have done that
because it was just so fun and we have
so many of this not so many but we have
a couple of the same gals going back
it's very similar which is always and
you know what we need a reunion totally
it's been too long yeah since we all
hung out what other questions do people
have Jackie um just really wedding
questions we're gonna be following you
on this journey
olivia is the busiest woman ever and so
I'm sure you will be back soon so
anytime that works out for me I will be
happy to be here I'm happy to have you
and we can just keep getting updates on
the wedding the road to the wedding the
road to the wedding
follow me in my workouts at the live
method at Olivia's Rae what else I don't
really post anything else right now
because truly all I do is work out which
you know everybody always says wedding
planning is so stressful so it's like
really great that I take my aggression
out on the planks and the lunges yeah
that's why I'm trying to lose weight now
so that like the month before my wedding
I'm not like crammed to lose weight and
I'm not an even bigger nightmare than I
probably will be agree I just I also
don't think he'll be that big of a
nightmare no here's the thing about like
I'm not a nightmare tour towards other
people but like internally there's a
nightmare happening when I if I go into
that mode and so like I'm not gonna
scream at everyone but I'm just gonna
like not I'm just gonna be like you like
to be combusting inside right yes so I'm
trying to avoid that for myself
for like the months before my wedding so
that's why I need to be like eating
something that I can't be like now it's
like Isis how its combusting for me I
worked out yesterday I was so sore all I
wanted to do is get into bed I got into
bed and Zach stupid air pods were right
there like standing up and I laid down
right on it and it went like right into
my side it was so painful I was like
girl can't even catch a break just to
lay down and enjoy then I went to shower
I was cleaning my ears and I stabbed my
[ __ ] ear with the q-tip and I
literally like started tearing up that
was it I can't catch a break and this
was the funniest part well I mean why me
no I do bad things Jackie to good people
want to laugh so hard so I was like oh
my god that did I ruptured my eardrum
I'm like this is just like I was like so
worried you know I started to Google
it's frightening don't do that but like
there was no blood so it was okay and I
went in the uber this morning to
come here I put my headphones in to
listen to music on my way in and in the
ear that I stabbed nothing was coming
out and I was like oh my god I can't
hear anything one year and then I looked
down and the pod wasn't in my ear
literally like you know in your heart
sinks I was just like oh my god and so
that's how things are manifesting for me
where it's like all the hard things have
been easy and all the easy things are
becoming hard and I'm just like I'm not
here for it I mean I'm like it's just
good to know that other people get to
this like anyone I talk to about like
wedding planning who's done it they're
like it gets better
yeah like it gets worse before it gets
better to know but like it's normal to
be beyond stress yeah it's hard for
everyone yeah so I'm not special yeah I
hear that
well I think you're special regardless
thank you I think you're special as well
yeah I know that was hard for you to say
thank you all for joining us today we
there will be no show on Monday because
both Claudia and I are oh oh oh but I
will be back on Tuesday with a guest
co-host I will let you know as soon as I
know and then Wednesday Claudia is back
so we can't wait to see you on Tuesday
I am off to Austin there any Austin
toasters let me know except I'm actually
really busy so like I probably can't do
a meet-up but we'll see you never know
you never know maybe I'll wake up early
as opposed to two o'clock probably not
probably not I'm very so funny I'm the
very really quickly so Jackie's friends
made a video of Zak almost like a
newlywed game tiny I did yeah did you
talk about it on the show a little bit
but I didn't talk about the specific
specific answers one of them was so
funny the question was like what is what
do you were you and Jackie for breakfast
and one of sacks answers was like yeah
you know like pizza and pasta when she
wakes up at 2:00 p.m. it's just like
totally shade but totally yeah anyways
thank you guys follow us at the morning
toast our Jackie O problems for the most
premium content per usual ad Olivia
ostrich always looking real good my flow
is my pride and joy like that's how else
to go when I have a child like just
checking it all the time making sure
it's perfect and beautiful and wonderful
and living in stress life totally thank
you guys have a good weekend
you